Whoa.
Season 3 of Sunny Family Cult on CryptTV gets
crazy.
If you want to hear all the hidden details
about the big connection between Look-See
and Sunny Family Cult, then what you’re
gonna want to do is watch this whole video.
From start to finish.
This video is sponsored by CryptTV.
Sunny Family Cult is back, and it picks up
right where Season 2 left off with Taylor
being driven into the desert… which confused
me a bit because I always thought they lived
in Iowa… there is actually an answer to
this question of how they end up in the desert,
in a now unlisted miniseries called Roger’s
Vlog, which takes place between Season 2 and
Season 3 and can only be found by looking
through the playlist section on Crypt’s
channel.
Let’s check it out.
“My dad won’t stop until he finds me.”
“Oh I believe that.
Absolutely.
But luckily, we’ve got four states in between
him and us, so, we’re farther away from
Iowa than he’s ever been in his entire life.”
Which puts them California.
Now Roger’s vlog doesn’t exactly go up
with Casey Neistat levels of consistency,
but we do get a little more information in
the second, and at the time of making this,
final vlog.
"When I started this cult about 20 years ago,
my brother didn’t realize the significance.
He didn’t see that there was a--”
“Can he see that you started the Sunny Family
Cult?”
“People have been talking about Sunny Family
for like 30 years, since like, the 80s.
The town’s full of stories.”
“Yes, there was a cult back in the 80s,
but it was not the Sunny Family Cult that
I started.”
This confirms what I predicted in my last
Things You Missed on Sunny Family Cult Season
1 and 2, about how Roger’s chapter of the
cult branches off of the original.
So after driving halfway across the country,
they end up in the motel in the California
desert.
But after attempting to escape and getting
a couple innocent people chopped up by Roger,
Taylor finds herself tied up in the motel
room.
“No more bringing chaos into the world to
show people what is really important, it’s
time to wipe it clean.
Start over.
Together.”
So as I mentioned before, Roger’s chapter
of the cult is the antithesis of Elias’s
chapter, and many of the flashback scenes
here in Season 3 show how that divide was
formed.
This line really spells out exactly how the
two values differ.
It’s mentioned from the very beginning how
the purpose of Elias’s cult is to introduce
chaos and disrupt bonality, and in season
3 we get to see exactly why those values are
adopted.
Taylor of course, being someone who has grown
up learning the ways of Elias, is naturally
repulsed by Rodger’s ideas, and has this
to say about him.
“You’re a monster.
No I’m not.
I need you for that.”
And that line leads us into the main plot
of this season, Roger’s conquest to fulfill
the ritual from this ancient book he found.
We get to see a little more of that book in
Episode 2, and it is filled with Things You
Missed.
This is the first page that we get a good
look at, and a closer inspection reveals that
it’s all about Look-See.
The Latin text, “tempus edax rerum” translates
to “time, devourer of all things.”
That, of course ties into Look-See’s iconic
accessory, his stopwatch.
There’s also a clock present on this page,
a sketch of Look-See’s hand and mouth and
the act of Look-See taking a body part, in
this case, the face, from someone who was
not able to release.
There’s also a much deeper possible connection
with Look-See that I’ll touch back on later
in this video.
The next page looks to be about Soot, the
newest CryptTV serialization, directed by
my very talented friend, Danny Donahue.
There’s only one episode of Soot out so
far, but the tagline is “Every Cycle must
be completed,” and the episode seems to
compare cycles of electricity and life cycles.
The Latin on the page to the right contains
the phrases, “he began to perish” and
“difficult for those in the highest…”
something, that’s where it cuts off.
The text also mentions something about selection,
and there is an image of a human eye.
I’m sure we’ll find more about how all
that ties into the themes of the series very
soon.
The next page doesn’t have any legible text,
but it does contain the symbol of The Birch,
the most popular short film on CryptTV, which
will also be serialized in the near future.
There’s also page on the the cursed statue
from another recent Crypt series, Stoneheart.
The Latin on the left page says something
about a sacred dance, thought I can’t make
out much more than that, and the English on
the right reads: “For she, the protector,
will strike down all that oppose those that
would denounce her name.
When for the stones the man cast will break
the bones of his enemies.
She seeks to redress that wrong.
Come to her and she will end all your pain.
All your…” and that’s where it cuts
off.
The next page is a bit more ambiguous, but
it shows what appears to be Aponi, the main
witch from Stoneheart.
And moreover, this is just a really cool illustration.
Moving on, the symbols on the left here are
not anything that I’m familiar with, but
if anyone has any leads on how to decipher
them, please let me know in the comments.
I’m sure you’re all familiar with the
Sunny Family Cult symbol, but what you may
have missed is when Roger moves his hand,
the shadow of another new creature can be
seen very briefly, before Roger turns the
page once again, and this is an important
one, because it details the ritual that becomes
the centerpiece of everything Roger is aiming
for in this season of Sunny Fam.
The whole reason Roger kidnaps Taylor, is
because he believes she is the one who can
help him unlock this hidden power.
She is the girl of 17 with violence etched
into her soul, with dark hair and dark eyes
pictured at the center here in this book,
and these monsters drawn above, Aponi, Mordeo
and Look-See, all existing Crypt creatures,
are examples of what kind of monsters might
be created from carrying out this ritual.
The diagram outlines 5 sacrifices and the
caption calls for: “a blood sacrifice of
four victims, and the fifth will become something.”
The other side details what I can only imagine
is the transformation process from man to
monster.
So after taking all of these pages in, Roger
looks up and see a vision of this girl.
This shot is very reminiscent of an image
from one of the lesser known Crypt short films,
The Woman In The Book, where not much background
is given about the story, but a similar looking
creepy lady seems to be summoned from a book
in that short as well.
Mr. Sandman also features a similar book,
so the idea of Crypt lore being hidden in
ancient texts has been established even before
Sunny Family Cult.
Now at this point, at the end of this second
episode of Season 3, you could chalk up all
of these references to other CryptTV properties
to be nothing more than fun easter eggs, but
going forward into episode 3, it becomes very
clear that all of these worlds are destined
to collide in Sunny Family Cult.
If you’re enjoying the video so far, you’ve
probably noticed this stylish attire.
If you want to be part of the Sunny Fam, you’ve
got to have this merch.
And there’s only one way to get it.
All you have to do sign up for the Crypt newsletter
using the link in the description, and you’ll
be in the know about their exclusive monthly
merch drops.
Now back to Things You Missed.
Remember back in Season 2, when Taylor and
Jaina are being chased by the masked Roger,
and Taylor asks Jaina, if she can see him
too, basically suggesting that she’s been
having hallucinations?
“You see him too?
What if those visions tie into Taylor’s
status as the chosen girl in the prophecy
of Roger’s book?
The third episode begins with a pair of hands
that should be familiar to anyone who’s
seen Look-See, attacking Taylor in her sleep.
She wakes up back in her room, where she sees
yet another monster rise up before her.
Based on the shadow on the wall, it looks
like Aponi.
But this is also just a dream.
As this episode progresses, it becomes more
and more clear that these are more than just
references.
Sunny Family Cult is the epicenter of a CryptTV
cinematic universe including all of their
monster properties.
The hastag, #MonsterWithin is more than just
a catchy tagline.
In this Crypt Universe, there’s a monster
within all of us, waiting to be unleashed
by this ancient ritual.
Roger is buying all into it.
He’s gone and got a tattoo with the Sunny
Family Cult logo at the center, the cursed
statue from Stoneheart, Look-See, Soot, and
the stick symbol from the Birch.
All of these icons have risen up from the
girl making the final sacrifice.
As Roger tries to convince Taylor to take
part, he tells her the following.
“We can do this together.
We can wipe away what we hate in this world.”
This is an interesting take because Roger
believes he is the good guy, and in the end,
he might be.
Look-See, Mordeo, Aponi, The Birch… all
of their victims tend to be criminals, bad
people or people with dangerous flaws.
“If that’s what you call a monster, then
yes.
We will turn ourselves into monsters.”
Taylor, of course, thinks this is insane,
and gets the heck out of there, taking refuge
in the motel manager’s office.
Unfortunately for her, Roger has been there
already.
For those of you keeping count at home…
I know one of you is…  that’s 3 kills at the motel.
Taylor uses his fingerprint to unlock his
phone and call her dad, who by the way has
a North Carolina area code.
I guess what Roger said about him never having
ventured this far from Iowa is still true.
That is… until episode 4, the season finale
It is at the this point, that we finally see
the face of the girl from Rodger’s visions,
and it looks exactly like Taylor.
A rush of images flash on screen very quickly.
Look-See.
The cursed statue from Stoneheart.
Troubled Youth.
Soot.
Mordeo.
Aponi.
And the famous monster from The Birch.
Taylor’s Dad showing up, ends up working
in Roger’s favor, because he unknowingly
becomes the fourth sacrifice at the motel.
It is as it is written in the book: four blood
sacrifices and the fifth will become something.
Taylor’s anger gets the better of her, and
she gives Roger exactly what he wants, making
him the fifth sacrifice and ending the season
on his revival.
I’m excited to see whatever monster Roger
becomes in the next season.
Because whatever it is really becomes the
biggest boss in all of CryptTV canon.
The bad guy that presides over all other bad
guys on the Crypt channel.
The one that brings each series together…
into one.
This is a really exciting time to be a follower
of the  Sunny Family Cult and the Crypt channel
in general.
There are series within this cinematic universe
airing right now, and you don’t want to
miss out, so make sure you subscribe to CryptTV
for scary episodes every Tuesday, Thursday
and Friday and I’ll see you in the next
one.
Assuming we both survive.